all right Mike and Stephanie
Mike and Stephanie where you guys from
originally Stephanie you grew up where
I grew up in Whittier and I
moved to Victorville and stayed out
there when in 10th Grade and from there
I lived out there
till now
tell me about your family Stephanie you
uh you're both your parents uh
I was uh
brother or anything thing um
she's two years older than me when I was
two and she was four
our debt our biological father
molestudus
um
then I had got a step-dad about
when I was
three and my sister was five so uh
they um never had really a stable life I
guess you can call it
um
stability was not
part of my life we were constantly
moving around and around or with people
or whatnot and so
um I've watched my parents uh go
um well my dad go in and out of jail
um
who's your dad in jail for
possessions or
um
mostly possessions of like math or
yeah stuff like that sexual abuse from
your dad my stepdad no my biological dad
yeah
yeah as soon as my mom found out about
my biological dad molesting me my sister
uh she divorced him you know how long
did that go on before she found out uh
a year a year so you were how old I was
two so when I was one he started that
with you and your sisters well yeah I
was one so my sister would have been
three
and then it continued for a year so then
when I was two and my sister was four is
when my mom found out because she never
knew she never knew
um about any of it until one day my
sister actually uh
brought it up because she was trying to
tell her that uh well she's four you
know and she was trying to say it hurts
when she goes to the restroom when she
pees and my mom didn't quite understand
what that why or what not but when she
further got into uh
it it came out that my sister told her
that you know Daddy does this or daddy
does that and uh so when my mom found
out about it uh she uh
divorced my dad
um and my mom thought it was funny
because she she's like they're trying to
give him 50 50 like custody you know why
would you want the kids with of the dad
that molested us you know like doesn't
make no sense
but I don't know that was back then so I
mean
but after that
[Music]
um
yeah so uh I had a step I got a stepdad
and
um like I said we lived with family on
and off or whatnot
um
I was never really in the streets and
homeless with my parents I guess you
call it I was more just living with
people you know I never had our own spot
our own stuff you know
um
and then uh
as kind of funny as we got older I'm
like there's only two of us me and my
sister but I'm like the black sheep bad
one and she's like she went it did
everything right you know like she
graduated high school she went and did
the college you know she's a nurse she
you know she has a family of her own now
and she doesn't do drugs she doesn't do
nothing you know all that stuff um me on
the other hand uh
well I guess I took the opposite Road
and I um
I have done a lot
so given the that you and your sister
both went through a similar abuse in
your childhoods
but she cannot she you know her life
took it a very different direction you
can't really
do you blame the child the sexual abuse
you know
no no
but at the same time
uh
I feel it did have some type of effect
with me and her later on in life because
even though she is you know turned
around and doing everything right and
stuff like she still has problems like
uh
trust Pro like men like with in her
relationship problems like uh you know
like trusty trust problems and like um
uh stuff like that like me too like I
have trust issues you know
um for a while I was a runner I just ran
if something happened I ran away that's
how I deal with my stuff
um until I met my husband actually uh he
uh
he was
I guess the person that taught me at the
I don't have to do that and that it's
okay to sit there and work out your
problems you know that's great how long
have you been and Mike been married
we've been married for
was I was 17 18 next year
for about five six years but we've been
together for like 13.
yeah I've been with them for 13 years
been married for to him for six years
that's great we have a son
and a daughter
Mike tell me about your childhood
um I grew up in pretty much the opposite
of that
um I'm both my parents work my mom's a
professor my dad's a mechanical engineer
friend how's your bush or he was
when he retired he got into real estate
was a real estate investor my mom
she was head of Department of Education
at the University of La Verne I had
every door open to me
um you know I threw over it all away
um
I was spoiled rotten as a kid I got
anything I wanted
um
but I didn't see my parents much
um
I I kind of raised myself
um it's
like with chore like I would have chores
of course in allowance but my chore list
was I would just have a list of stuff I
could do with the amount that
um it was worse so if I wanted to mow
the lawn I could do so and it was like
ten dollars or whatnot so I'd make my
own paycheck and
um
I mean and there was never I never went
without it as a child
um
I
I didn't even understand that concept
until I was on my own
um
and like her I'm the black sheep of the
family
um that
I have my
my with my biological father I have four
sisters
um one of them is three months apart
from me so my biological father was
jumping over the backyard fence being
with the neighbor at the same time he
was with my mom
and so my mom and him didn't work out
and she married my dad
um he adopted me and when I was in sixth
grade and
he's an amazing guy
um but his kids are a lot older than I
was so we never really related
um
and I mean with that I mean he also he
worked 12-hour shifts probably about
five six days a week he'd pick up as
much overtime as he could so I mean I
would never see them my mom she worked
and went to school
and created a few companies of her own
so I mean she wasn't around either
I mean that's pretty much how my
childhood went
the uh the addiction that you picked up
kind of took but it started with my my
brother my brother I caught my brother
getting stoned
and um he got me high so I wouldn't tell
Mom and Dad
and then from that point on I just the
chase was on I I would go out of my way
to try to find him so I could get high
and just started real fast from that I
mean with him being 10 years older than
me I got into
kind of the older crowd and what drug
did he
get you started on pot and then but I
mean I've done coke with him too at a
young age at 12 I was doing coke was my
brother
when I first did pot I was nine
which we were just talking about it
that's
I mean could you imagine our daughter
just turned 14.
um yesterday right yeah on the 18th on
the 18th yeah
so that's like her doing
anything and that's weird yeah your kids
are aware
my daughter's with my mom and my son is
my parents actually just adopted our son
um
when like last week
yeah
yeah we've been fighting it for
as long as we could and
um
I mean it was either
go up against them and lose our chance
at visitations and um
everything else or to sign over the
adoption
for them
so we decided to um
keep our visits with our son and and let
my parents take care of them
or at least be responsible for them
right and what do you guys go through
emotionally
letting your you know having your kids
taken care of by your parents
it sucks
yeah
it's
I
it's like being a kid all over again
having your parents get to dictate
everything
that you're allowed to do if you want to
have your son in your life
I don't know for me it's different for
me it sucks like
my daughter
you know I never
understood
the concept of time I guess
and
through
in and out of jail to
rehabs to all the time in the world that
I have spent away from them
to not understanding just the little
things in life like um
she gets to have all of those moments
that I
so desperately want
she gets to see them grow or both of my
his and my parents get to watch our kids
grow up and
it's awesome when you get to see your
kids see the something for the first
time or experience it
it it just it does something you know
and I don't get that and I don't get any
of that anymore and it really sucks
um
I think to myself sometimes like wow you
know there's so many people out there
that have kids that don't even care
don't even try to want to be in their
kids lives you know and I don't
understand how or why but
here I am wanting so bad
to just get more time with my kid
or anything and I
can't get it because of everything I've
ever done in my past and so when they
say you know
make good choices or
your you know it it follows you like
everything you do it does follow you and
um
I guess nowadays if you have the money
to make it go away or fix it you know
cool but if you don't and you rely on
resources that are like free to public
or
anything free I guess you could call uh
you're not gonna go far
you're not
and it does suck uh and then the
depression I mean just from it just it's
a it's a cycle it just sucks it's like
the depression brings you back to the
drugs and then it's that but the drugs
is what takes you away from everything
is I don't know it doesn't even make
sense I don't even like holidays anymore
I don't I don't uh
yesterday I got to call my my daughter
because I haven't talked to her and what
a couple weeks or
or so my phone got lost or whatever and
but I made sure to be able to call her
on her birthday and she cried she was
like Mommy I miss you I love you you
know and
it's not good because I have to
I have to look at it as this am I giving
them
estate am I giving them stability am I
giving them am I taking care of them
better than where they are now
and for a lot of the part no
um
as much as I want them and as much as
they're down here no and
see if you're not an addict you
you're not gonna understand
but it is
when they say it's a disease it is a
disease and you can go to rehab as many
times as you want but
it's gonna it doesn't go away after you
complete a program
it doesn't just disappear you know
you're not oh yeah I'm not an addict no
more no you still are every day of your
life you still are you gotta like they
say live one day at a time because
you know apparently I'm a person where I
like to mask my problems and I like to
I don't want like to feel my my feelings
so I go to use a
to
so I don't have to fail to numb it
right and but it's like a Band-Aid you
know he numbs it for so long and then
you know
um
then life on life terms come back and
it's like getting a Band-Aid ripped off
it's like boom there it is now deal with
it again and it's just a vicious cycle
that's what they call what Insanity
right
something that happens
that you relive over and over again
yeah expecting having expectations and
expecting different results when you're
not doing anything different
you know
um
I guess that you call I look for the
easy way out instead of the hard because
I don't know about anybody else but me
living on life on life terms sober is
one of the most hardest things I've ever
done
hardest but it's not easy you know
um but some people it comes easy for
some people
it it's
you know
um
I mean I don't know I I don't understand
sometimes why I choose the things I do
or why I choose to use instead of not
um
I do know it's something that
I
wish I was able to control
a lot more than I do now because I don't
feel like I have any control over it at
all like you do whatsoever do you think
that's in part because of what you went
through as a young girl
I think
you see that's where that that's that's
where that whole my sister and I have
both lived the same life right and she
went different and I went different
right
so that goes back in my head right like
um
but you're also different personalities
different DNA it's true yeah yeah we did
go we did experience pretty much almost
like the same things right together
um because we are together so
um you know
yeah I don't know I think they're also
very different ages that's true she was
three or four and you were one or two
yeah but even even though maybe you were
too young to even know that anything was
going on
maybe that didn't impact you emotionally
but having a father that would could do
that
yeah plays a big role in your life right
it wasn't like your dad just did that
whatever you did when you were two and
then no he was a great dad the rest of
the time he was probably yeah he's on
Megan's Law if you looked at my dad he's
on Megan's Law right now like that's
Mega's list yeah at Megan's list yeah
so I mean so he's done it with other
yeah yeah obviously yeah other children
yeah obviously so um having a sex
offender as a father
right a pedophile is a father right is
uh you know it's not something you want
to brag about
um it just I feel like a lot of my
childhood does have an effect of it on
on my adulthood I think uh throughout
life any kid what they go through now in
their life has a
really big effect on them
as an adult definitely definitely that's
why you try to give your kids something
better than what you have
right because you don't want them to
grow up
I don't know messed up or
just feeling like life's hard when
maybe in reality it's not you know
but today my reality it is
and it
using is not something I would wish upon
anybody to be honest with you you know
um
I have really small veins I have really
deep veins it's really hard to hit you
know and
it's ugly and where do you guys stay now
are you on the streets uh that one Park
what is it called
North Hollywood Park yeah so you're on
the streets basically yeah yeah and what
do you
what do you do for money
what we're doing now or well this
doesn't happen every day no it doesn't
but um but this is another hustle
another hustle right many you know
something comes along every day that's
different do you get into doing things
that you
uh when your partner might have a hard
time you know I have to sit here and say
that I've honestly
you know have told myself like you have
morals right as a person you have you
grow up feeling like okay I'll never do
that or I'll never do this you know and
like I have to sit here and honestly say
like through my addiction I had done
stuff I never thought I would do
um you know just to get money and get by
or whatnot you know going from stealing
or you know
um never was the type to um
sell my body or anything
um for money but
um I definitely would steal
that's a lot of the reasons why I have
gone to jail
and my record is you know not so well a
lot of it is just like Grand Theft petty
theft
goes on and on you know your drugs now
are
yeah and that's going to be terribly
difficult to quit yeah it is and it's
not pretty like you know yeah I've never
thought in a million years I would ever
be you know married to a person you know
uh
at all uh I've always wanted it but I
never thought you know it happened let
alone you know now what going on 13
years but
um I could tell you one thing like
I don't understand why the guy right
here is sitting next to me today
and still loves me
because I've done
some pretty
mean things I guess you know I haven't
been the nicest person you know I've
probably called him every name in the
book I probably I mean I've gotten as
far as give his [ __ ] [ __ ] away
literally like set it outside my
doorstep and everything everything I had
just put on the curb yeah
sentimental stuff like that you can't
get back you know that he got from his
grandma or whatnot I didn't realize it
was in there but it still it didn't make
it right
um I've gone
from that to uh fighting with him you
know
um one time it did get physical but
thank God it was only one time
um [ __ ] the drug dealer
[ __ ] a drug dealer to get him back
because I went to jail one time for six
months and I got out and he was living
with another girl and
they were all supposedly In Love from
what she said and everything so I was
like well [ __ ] you then what is good for
you how do I hurt you oh yeah money you
love money well I'm gonna go [ __ ] your
drug dealer then and I did
and come to find out I did that one time
and it has haunted me for the rest of my
life now he does not let me forget it um
I ended up giving him a disease over it
um the only STD I've ever had
yeah
um I mean I have been pretty [ __ ]
horrible person
to say the least with Mike's still by
your side
yeah
I understand addiction yeah see that's
what I was going to say
having a partner who's an addict can
probably understand how it affects how
it changes your personality changes who
you are I'm not any better
I mean I I understand I get it but like
that whole Trust
part where you need to trust your
partner you know and that whole
we still have to work on that every day
like you know it's not easy
it's just
he don't trust me
I don't trust him
how do you get it back you want it back
he desperately want it it's no longer
something that's better it's something
that we both have to learn exactly just
like I have to now earn everything back
my thank you I have to learn
that my kids I have to earn them back I
have to earned I mean I went from having
an apartment with my husband and a job
and everything else in a car and a dog
to literally I mean it started with
Heroin but it ended with fentanyl water
can't even say ended it's still so I
mean but
having all of that and literally it took
everything down to my freedom
away
and
I just
I'm ha I'm lucky to be able to say right
now that he loves me and that he's
willing to be here and still want want
to
try to work things out
and have our family
you're my best friend
you're my best friend
and I never loved anybody
as much as I love him
I'm a handful of myself
but he's taught me a lot you know things
about myself and
about life like since I've been with him
because like I said like
if anything ever happened
to where it didn't work out for me or
whatnot I would run that's how I solve
problems like oh well
I don't I I'll just leave that alone and
go somewhere else you know
um I wouldn't let it run yeah he never
let me read he just chased me through
death
I can tell just
I can tell just I just met you guys just
you know 20 minutes ago half an hour ago
I can tell that Mike is very
evolved he really understands what you
guys are going through what he's going
through what you're going through yeah
and his ability to forgive and and
write out the
the BS that you're going through
right it makes him a great partner
because he it does I'm more of a
catastrophic size I guess I don't know
if that's the right word with things and
I make things uh that haven't even
happened you know just thinking about it
like you know like into a big deal and I
can't see the bigger picture a lot of
times I just see what's right in front
of me instead of trying to see what is
the whole thing and he's very good at
that he is very good at seeing the
bigger picture and uh
not just focusing on what is right here
right now because you you've got to
think
and gotta see like what the bigger
picture is and think outside the box
sometimes in life and
you know that's where the trust Falls in
and let me tell you something like I I
trust him with my life like
I was visiting up with my parents one
day and we were walking down the street
back to their house and out of the blue
we were waiting to cross the street a
car came around the corner and started
shooting at me and my husband literally
like it was as close as me and you are
maybe closer
just shooting
and it wasn't like an automatic I think
and immediately with not even a question
no nothing he flipped around and stood
right in front of me like like it was
just a natural reaction and that could
have killed him like at any given time
like you know I at least I know he would
honestly take a bullet for me
honestly like yeah
yeah he would he would definitely you
know
um
I've tried to live without him he's
tried to we tried that we tried
uh
to live without one another but we
always end up
right back
to each other there's sex we do good on
our own
like we'll both get off drugs
and start doing the family thing like
her parents hate me my parents aren't
too fond of her so I get more of the
relationship with my son and she gets
more of the relationship with our
daughter
and I mean that's what our lives go back
to when we're away from each other but
we're miserable
completely miserable completely
miserable and then it's as soon as we
get back together we don't have the
support from anyone and so we lose and
so we go back to what we know and it
it's just a vicious cycle like we were
just arguing today this morning before
we got here about his mom
and how
she I started out saying that you know
she's like oh because I'm supposed to
have our visitation today that's what we
just went to court for and stuff and she
decides that she doesn't want to have it
it's not a good day today that tomorrow
is a better day no it's our last day in
Disney World today okay they're on
vacation and because of that she wants
to go and move it till tomorrow well
that's not why this whole Court thing
happened like if you have a court
ordered anything you're supposed to
follow that no matter if you're on
vacation or [ __ ] not it doesn't
matter
and so he didn't talk to me about it and
he just told her yeah go ahead so when I
asked him when our visitation was he's
like well find out what it is and I just
put hi what time is our visitation he
was like upset about it it made him
upset because he's like it sounded rude
I guess or the way she would take it it
would sound rude and I told him I'm not
trying to be her friend I just want my
visitation with my son in my book right
now your mom is not at that is not my
priority level like she just took my son
away and I I'm not trying to tell you
have a relationship with it but just be
more cordial
you'll get a lot more but my point is is
that like we are until this day right
now still having those issues and it's
something that we're going to be having
until
we figure it out and we find other
different solutions the last time I saw
her parents her dad hit me with a
Maglite and busted my head this is true
very true it's like a month ago yeah
very true
so I mean
it's a kind of messed up it's a tough
life it is it's a tough life I'm not
gonna lie have you tried to get clean
yeah yeah it's
it's such horror stories about trying to
get clean from Fentanyl it really is
like you know um I don't know how many
times I've already died off of it and
he's brought me back to life
and he gets mad now because he's like we
just fought about that too
I'm tired of seeing you die and I have
to bring you back it's an ugly [ __ ]
thing and feeling and I don't like it
and you don't care as long as you know
that we have Narcan it's okay and it's
like are you smoking or you're injecting
it
um smoking
um
still dying though some people can
tolerate a lot of it in others he has
never died and he can probably smoke
[ __ ] Eric I couldn't even tell you I
mean to tell you the truth he could
probably smoke as much as he can
possibly smoke and still not die like I
don't know what it is no it's not but
I'm just saying like
it's really ridiculous it's tolerance I
know I was just saying that's how high
your tolerance is
um it's not a nice life it's not
it's not it's hard yeah
and you feel like you are gonna die if
you don't have it like literally people
talk [ __ ] about like homeless people or
drug addicts like go get a job you don't
work we work our [ __ ] asses off all
day every day
and you have to to be a drug addict
all right Mike what would you say is the
the most misunderstood thing about
people in your situation
that all of them are the same yeah but
I'd love to hear Mike's take on this
it's it's hard to to say because a lot
of the stereotypes
um
are true but
it's it's the drug it's not it's not the
person like with a lot of things that we
do
like I wouldn't I wouldn't go steal
anything if if I didn't have to
but I I'm not rich I don't have an
endless bank account I
and I've
I've done everyone wrong in my life
that's given me an opportunity
so I don't have any more opportunities
and it's
I mean I it you feel like you're stuck
on the bottom like and you don't know a
way out
and I mean even with the help like
I mean
I mean you you mess up one time and you
get shunned and then
yeah I mean you're pretty much the only
way to get
um I mean
I don't know I don't understand a lot of
it like the people like that were just
your friends like it in N A or a a
second you use everybody turns their
back on you and it's like for me like I
would think like that would be like the
time you'd want to help the most
like let the people know like what
they're gonna lose you know I mean like
don't like tell them that they lost
already
and you don't really you don't see that
you see a lot of kicking them while
they're down
for people in our situation and it gets
to the point where
we get like why try anymore
um
you give up after a while
your drug takes away everything that you
love and it becomes the only thing left
it also takes away the pain yeah it
numbs you you you it's all you need
but you don't have it you're [ __ ]
um all that comes rushing right back
is there any solution that you can
come up with
don't use
don't use in the first place yeah
um that's why I do these
do whatever you can to stop
I mean
all of my yets as a child
when I I got in trouble
um with an ounce of cocaine when I was
like 13 or 14.
and they made me go to AAA meetings and
a meetings
and at the time I had a bunch of yet
like I haven't done that yet I don't
have really
any yets left
and it's the same story for everyone
um
I wish I knew now
I mean I wish I knew then what I know
now
I wish I could
go back and like tell myself what an
idiot I am
and all that I'm going to be losing
ah
I want nothing more than just to be a
husband and a dad
and I have had the opportunity to have
both of those and I threw them away
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I love you
it's difficult to watch two people that
are so aware and
capable of doing better but just stuck
in this quicksand yeah well fentanyl
addiction
sure is it's hard to watch
because I can see that you guys could do
better
if you just didn't have that on your
back
I've done better I was a loan officer
for eight years for a mortgage company
I've gone to college
um
and now I I'm homeless and I use drugs
do you look at do you look at your
current situation sometimes and just go
what the [ __ ] how did this happen yeah
every day
every day
and then I get high and stuff it stuff
all that pain
is sick
it's really [ __ ] sick
I really want to wish this
on anybody
like I I don't hate anybody that much
you'd have to really hate somebody
twist this life on somebody
I don't even know if I would wish that
on My Own Worst Enemy that's what I'm
saying
I'm not too fond of your mom but I don't
ever wish that upon her
foreign
it's just it's not fun
I mean don't give me there's there's a
lot of fun
but it's not worth it
it is such an illusion it I have my the
fun for me last left a long time ago
yeah me too but
it was there
in the beginning I guess long time ago
yeah
and the older you get
the harder it is
that I could say
though for I don't know whatever reason
but for me the older you get the older
I've been getting the harder it is to to
quit
yeah the detoxes get worse yeah longer
your body just it knows what it has to
do to
to get what it it wants it doesn't
bounce back like it used to
isn't that the truth yeah
especially when you're still living like
a high schooler
right
all right Mike and Stephanie thank you
so much for
sharing your stories
you're welcome thank you yours is one of
the most interesting
couple interviews I've ever done
thank you
you guys are both amazing thank you very
much you're welcome